what are the the pros and cons of
camping and how does only fans map into
this did you switch to only fans at some
point I did yeah
five or six years and I burned out
eventually what are the good aspects
what are the bad aspects of Cami well
the good aspects were it's just your own
terms you get to decide everything about
it is under your control which I loved
at the time I was like I can work when I
want how I want any sort of expression I
experimented and I was very successful I
was making around 200 an hour which for
that website at the time was like pretty
good
um I had elaborate routines I was a mime
I would do like dress up as a lime and
then dress up a chair and I would seduce
the chair
oh cool yeah or like it was almost it
was was there an artistic element to it
almost yeah very much
no I was a mime you know oh sorry uh
right yeah get it straight dude
you know what I really appreciate about
you is I'm asking some really dumb
questions and you're answering in a very
intelligent way so I appreciate that all
right did you ask the chair questions
I wasn't mine you idiot okay I'm
sorry
but there's gnomes on the like big nose
or small gnomes like lawn gnomes lawn
gnomes and you seduced the lawn gnome on
the chair The Gnome thing and there were
some yeah gnomes in the chair I I did a
photo set which I submitted to Reddit
where I got abducted I was like
stripping uh taking my clothes off and
then slowly the Gnomes surrounded me in
the background then dragged me off and I
did this as a photo set essentially uh I
mean I mean I didn't feel consensual in
the photos but okay but it was
the it was very successful in Reddit
basically it was a top person Gone Wild
in the 11th top post of all time which I
think will probably just means it's like
it's it's artistic it's interesting it's
edgy it's funny it's also really really
well done but it was really shocking to
be that nobody else was doing anything
creative with sex work like for me it
was it was like breathing like you're
just doing sex and you're bored I'm like
what do you do I don't know let's try
something funny like it's just the
natural progression and it felt to me
like there was almost no competition
like I would just be really creative and
like immediately lose the top not safe
for work post on Reddit I'm like well I
didn't even try that word and so it's
really shocking to me that other women
who are doing this sort of thing is that
uh still a little bit of the case
that there's not as much like because I
for my sort of outside of perspective
that seems to be still the case like
there's not like as you describe it
that's kind of cool that's like almost
like
playing like having fun with sexuality
almost yeah
that's and yeah but that does require
kind of thinking through
it's almost like a creative project like
a like a photography project or
something like that almost like a little
skit movie it's interesting is this Vibe
of like how can you like bring like
vibrant novelty to whatever you're doing
anything you're doing and I really like
doing this with surveys too like I've
been doing a lot of standard surveys but
I'm also like experimenting with novel
creative artistic surveys I'm like how
do you ask a question in a way that's
like beautiful and unusual and like a
thing is completely groundbreaking like
nobody's ever like you always make
everything so poetic and romantic it's
disgusting no
uh but yes I think you have that engine
in your head I guess of creativity like
yeah the way you ask questions which is
not trivial to do like for uh it's
actually very difficult to do
like good survey questions and I mean
we're joking but like yeah almost like
Poetic because you have to ask a
question in a way that doesn't lead to
the answer yes like you have to
you have to kind of inspire them to
think and then indirectly get at the
truth this is very it's a it's an art
form honestly yeah and also in a way
where they don't misinterpret the
question because it's amazing how you
any question you think oh this is the
clearest question possible no you're
wrong it has to be even clearer right
willingly or unwillingly because like
you also have to defend against that
question being criticized later when you
publish about it all that you have to
think about it all I think this might be
my greatest strength so I'm not very
good at statistics I'm not like great at
presenting data but I think probably my
greatest strength is in fact survey
design and like a question phrasing
because I've I've I have treated so many
thousands of polls and every single one
I get people telling me like the way
that they misinterpreted the poll so
it's like it's like you've become gone
through fire and then again I I'm
testing the phrasings all the time like
what happens if you slightly shift
phrasings and so I'll do the same
question test over time to see how it
changes and the way the the framing
affects the results
so the good and the bad of the caming
she said good the what was it I forgot
you mean the freedom the freedom to be
also be to be creative yeah
and that is just it was exhausting the
the site that I was on the way that it
structured is that you're ranking on the
site and thus the amount of people that
see you and that's the amount of money
you are on you earn is affected by the
amount of money that you earn on average
over the last 60 days so if you're
streaming and nobody's tipping you this
means that you're going to be dropping
down in the rankings which is going to
make it harder in the future okay so the
rich get richer in that site yeah so
it's very high pressure like if you're
on you need to be making money
as fast as you can if you want to
continue to make money so that was
really stressful it was very mentally
taxing I would do it for a couple hours
and just log off and be completely
exhausted because you're just like on as
hard as you can and this is why I have a
little PTSD streaming like I've
considered Twitch streaming I try a
little bit and and I'm I'm like I
haven't fully integrated the fact that
you don't have to be like maximally
entertaining every single second yet you
can actually just chill out and take it
slow and nothing bad happens yeah yeah
you can just enjoy silence yeah
did you feel lonely
doing it
I mean even just streamers feel lonely I
moved into a house with cam girls
does that make it better or worse better
they're great I'm still friends with
them to this day also there was like a
team almost like we're in this kind of
together yeah so we would like work
together and you know stream together
and
swap our clothes and stuff
it was great I swap ideas too soft ideas
yeah and uh actually on a small tangent
maybe a big tangent what do you think
because it's a recent controversy of
Andrew Tate
and that he I think in the past ran a
caming business and he's being accused
of sex trafficking what do you think
like from your own experience
what do you understand about Andrew Tate
is he a good person is he a bad person
is there something Shady about his
practices or not I wish I could answer
but I don't know I haven't looked into
it at all I've heard people talking
about I just haven't bothered to go into
it it is well known that like when I was
doing it back in the day the Eastern
European models had something different
going on though it was like a Trope
about you know there's the Eastern
European battles and then there's
everybody else they're there what it's
like darker or something like they do
Studios and they're lower quality
which means what the studios are you go
into like a warehouse and then they have
set up a little like things that
replicate bedrooms yeah but they're just
like stalls
and then you give you rent out or you
pay the studio percentage of your income
and you can tell when something looks
like a studio it's like a type of
background yeah that if you're like
watching enough it kind of starts to you
notice the patterns so like the
standards are lower there in the ethical
boundaries are a little looser yeah I
thought people are treated it's Uncle we
didn't I never heard anything about the
ethical site I just knew that it was
like lower quality like the girls seemed
like they were less into it and like
Carriage less how does this all
interplay with like sex trafficking so
consensual versus non-consensual I would
be strong ER never any non-consensual
camping
um I mean I guess it's like if it were
going to happen to that point be
surprised if it were in fact Eastern
European models based on this is
outdated this is I'm just thinking of my
stereotypes back what I can't a lot sure
so some of that is stereotyped versus
like collecting good data right yeah I
haven't done data on cam girl it's hard
I mean it's hard it's even hard to get
that data right
um yeah and obviously a really important
problem there's a method that I'm trying
that I really like I designed a survey
type which is like asking people who you
know yeah like who do you who do you
know who's done this and you tell me
like oh do you know anybody who's a
doctor do you know anybody who you know
has had cancer or like smokes or
personally I mean yeah personally just
do you know anybody yeah um and then if
you ask about a whole bunch of things
you can calibrate the responses so like
that's really interesting if you're if
your population you know 20 of them know
doctors and then you know the actual
amount of doctors then you can tell like
how this is corresponding like what is
the visibility of doctors so you can
reconstruct the graph basically yeah and
and we can do this with sex trafficking
and of course people are going to be
like well sex trafficking is not visible
people you don't know those I'm like
well then we can ask about other
non-visible things that other people
don't know that we do have data for like
homelessness or being in jail or like uh
if you have been like sexually assaulted
a lot of people don't like talking about
if they've been sexually assaulted so
you can do a whole bunch of things that
are like similarly suppressed in
knowledge in some way that we do
actually have rates for and then compare
that to the graph when we ask people do
you know anybody who's in sex trafficked
yeah so again this is not perfect I'm
not saying this is for things you can
infer things about that graph
but let's say we don't have good ways of
measuring sex trafficking right now
anyway I did a big deep dive into the
research that we have and sex
trafficking in the western world and the
actual like I read the studies and like
reports about the studies and it's
really pitiful we have terrible data
it's like there's just like vague
estimations made from one guy in a
basement in the 80s that's like the
basis for like one big study that like a
lot of people report on it was and so
I'm like okay so the the method I'm
proposing obviously is not perfect but
like the bar is so low at this point
well I wonder also if there's a ways to
design a survey that gets at the um at
the victims of sex trafficking also
which is they presumably have public
access to the internet and
I wonder how many of them are distinctly
aware that they're victims like it's
asking the question
when you're inside of a toxic
relationship are you inside of a toxic
relationship I mean if if the toxic
relationship is truly toxic sometimes
your your mind is with right
you're not you don't even know what's
true yeah so it's interesting if you can
design surveys actively sex right yeah
who could break through that so
basically get data on how many people
are getting sex trafficked directly oh
yeah like if you don't frame it like if
you don't say the word sex trafficking
you're like are you just in a situation
where you'd and maybe through the survey
I mean that's very meta but through the
survey help them you know I did this
this is what started my relationship
surveys so I've done a series of
relationship surveys and that was
because I knew somebody in a terrible
relationship and I was like I bet if she
took a survey where she answered
questions about her relationship and at
the end got a score that compared her to
everybody else she'd be like oh wait
everybody else has much better
relationships than I do so that's why I
started making the relationship surveys
was exactly for that reason yeah that's
really really powerful to know that like
you're not
you're not crazy for thinking this is a
bad relationship right or I think like
the actual question is like could you do
better if you broke up I think that the
thing that keeps most people in their
relationships is like this is the best
that I can do like this is normal and if
if it were normal I would say that they
are right like if you live in a culture
where everybody is abusing their their
people in the relationships then yeah
you I mean what are you gonna do break
up and then just be alone for the rest
of your life most people don't want to
do that but not comparing yourself to
this to the average is good to know to
know no your options are at least
understand it because you know being
normal is not always like this
conversation is not always great
um
meaning this this conversation is
anything but normal okay and uh
that was a tangent on a tangent about a
niche passion which is really
fascinating that you're playing with
those kinds of ideas of uh survey design
uh but back to camming so
um what were the cons what were the
negatives of Cami oh like the exhaustion
of just like live like the high pressure
yeah that was probably the worst thing
so not was there what about the
interaction with different people like
the Dynamics of the interaction with the
with the fans I guess I had a pretty
great time I mean it obviously wasn't
perfect because it's the internet but I
don't know there's there's a this is the
thing that confuses me a lot because a
lot of women that I know complain about
being harassed by men quite a lot
they're like you know men are always you
know groping harassed you know you have
to be paranoid in the club people are
like they're always laughing on you and
there's like Jesus Christ get away man
and I do not have this experience or
like maybe I do but I'm interpreting it
differently I don't know the thing is I
don't know what causes me to have such a
different experience from these women
that are like really feel really uh
hostile towards men and my guess is that
there's some sort of like very subtle
signaling that we're accidentally doing
you're like no fault of our own I'm not
saying this is a virtue I'm saying like
maybe it's just genetic or the fact that
women are doing that the women are doing
yeah like that and it might be just
something I'm completely accidentally
through no intention like happening to
Signal the thing that is causing men to
not view me as like a desirable Target
or like a Target at all what about the
flip side maybe you're not sensitive to
the
the creepy stare yeah that also might be
true the dude who's like God like is
undressing you with his eyes
that like in in a creepy way that you're
just not you don't like worry about it
you're or you're not touch like that the
fear of that the anxiety of that the the
the unpleasantness of that just doesn't
hit you I think that's also at least
part of it maybe all of it yeah yeah I
think there's there's some evidence for
it I think often like guys will do a
thing to me and I'm just like that's a
thing cool I I don't have any negative
response whatsoever that's
call back to the tire it's a thing this
is nice that happened it was good to
know that like I once had like a
homeless guy like asked me to come back
to my place baby and I was like this is
fun yeah like I'm like do you want me to
I love asking men like are you trying to
get me to have sex with you just like
saying it out front and they'll be like
well
usually they stop for a minute they're
like well uh yeah I mean I would like to
have sex and I'll be like thanks for
asking but I'm not interested in having
sex with you
and that's great I don't know I have no
issues with that interaction but like
maybe this is the kind of thing that
other women would find to be really
offensive so you have that conversation
and it doesn't turn into like a
threatening feel no like with the
homeless guy no no I've never had that
happen though but I think there's
something I think I'm doing something
like again this is kind of accidental
like I'm just am like this always and I
think I just happen to be like this at
people and they don't expect it like
they don't expect me to be like really
nice while explicitly asking them what
their intentions are like directly
putting my finger on the thing that like
oh you're trying to have sex with me and
then also not judging them for it yeah
um I think this like throws people off a
little bit so they don't get aggressive
they're like oh you're Autistic or
something even the cloak of anonymity on
the internet you weren't getting yeah I
just think I'm just not reactive and or
maybe I'm giving off I don't know I
don't know what's going on maybe it's
both maybe it's a feedback loop so I
just I had a pretty good experience I
know not everybody did definitely people
reported having antagonistic experiences
but when I was skimming I generally
really liked people are really nice to
me had a great time
made friends